only one thing can make a quick hitch
better and that is having some quick
change pins for the top hook
you have flexibility to go up and down
depending on your attachments and lots
of times you don't need to but when you
want to change this top hook height or
just take it off and put on one of those
top link adapters having the ability to
do so quick man it's hard to beat we're
going to put these on right now
this quick hitch is the most popular we
sell it does not use bushings a direct
pin fit to category one attachments you
order that from Good Works tractors.com
we ship Nationwide but get these quick
change pins from bolt on hooks.com
foreign thank you
[Music]